I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello! Hi there! Offs ladies. Hello!
Hi there! Dun dun dun dun. It is... Roy's wedding. I mean... It's a beautiful wedding! So beautiful! Roy and Laura are getting married.
In a beautiful backyard garden. I know. There's piano playing. We'll get to the stage. Champon? It is season 9 episode 2, Roy's Wedding, written by Alison Silverman and directed by Matt Sone. Here's your summary.
Pam and Jim attend Roy's Wedding. Yeah. And there are so many surprises. Yeah. So many things they didn't know about Roy and his growth and it gets them to wonder. Hmm, do we know everything about one another? Or is maybe Jim keeping a giant secret from Pam?
Uh-oh. Meanwhile in this episode, Clark schemes to get Aaron alone in his apartment. Clark's gonna be a creeper y'all. He sure is, and Nelly is gonna use an unusual tactic to get Dwight to cooperate in her charity special project. But before we get to all of that, we have a very special treat today.
Yeah, Jenna is super excited because it means no fast facts. Yes, Angela, you know me very well. That's right, today it means no fast facts. Yes, Angela, you know me very well. That's right. Today, there are no fast facts. Today, our top of show is an interview with Tim Meadows. Yay! We were so excited to have Tim.
Our regular office ladies listeners, you might remember a while back, Tim shared some tidbits with us when we broke down the episode, The Client. But we were thrilled to have him on the podcast in person. We did a Zoom. He talked about his time on the show, and we get to catch up with him. Yes.
Tim and I are also both in the new Mean Girls movie, which comes out this Friday, January 12th. We talk all about it. We talk about his time in the office and lots of other stuff. We had so much fun. We did. We got so tickled. We laughed so hard. We were all about it, we talk about his time in the office, and lots of other stuff. We had so much fun! We did! We got so tickled, we laughed so hard, we were all crying. I think there might be some pauses in this interview where you just hear three people silent laughing. Get ready for it!
Here it is. Oh my gosh, look who's here. It's Tim! Hi! Hello everyone! Hello. We are so excited to have you here with us. And you're going to talk a little bit about your time on the office and your new movie with Jenna. Mean girls. Let's start with the office. Tim, we always ask people how they got their job on the office. And you originally, you were offered the role and you turned it down, right? Yes, that is true.
I wouldn't say turned it down. I didn't turn it down to Greg and Michael Schur. I turned it down to my manager. Like he called and said, like, oh, we got this offer for this episode. And I was like, no, I don't know. I don't know if I should do it or not. Because actually, honestly, I was hoping to get paid more.
And then we had no money. It wasn't the very beginning. There was no money. It was the second season, I think. But only the second season. And NBC was not, you know, they were like not into paying me more money. And so I passed. And I just told my agent, right?
And then my manager's assistant called me back on his personal phone and said, I really think you should do this. And I don't make these kind of calls all the time. But I think that this is like one of those comedies that everybody in the industry watches. And I think you should do it. And I knew Steven, and I knew some of the other people
involved in the show too. So I was just like, okay, yeah, I'll do it. But it would have been nice if they came back and begged me, like, you know, to have a mic with Sure come back and go, hey, Tim, come on, please do this, sir. But that never happened. Okay. Well, Tim, you were our very first quote unquote stunt casting.
You were our first name actor to come on the show. It was a big thing. It was a big buzz. Mm-hmm. Yes. Yeah. I do remember I was very flattered actually because I'd say almost everybody in the cast came by because we weren't on the regular office set.
We were at the chili set. And I think I kind of remember a lot of people coming by to say hello because I was there and I was pretty impressed by that. God, I wish I had to take pictures and stuff like we do now, you know? Right, I know. I know.
I didn't do any of that. There's fantastic bloopers from that day too for folks that get the DVDs. I mean, when you come in and sing, I know you're scripted to come in at the end of the line, you know, but when you start singing that, I want my baby back, baby, and then Steve comes into this. It's so great. And we had Melora on the podcast and there she is seated between the two of you. And she said it was like one of the hardest things she's ever had to do is not laugh. Yeah.
In the very beginning, I remember we were trying to do it. And Steve was going like, he would start going, I want my baby back, baby back. And then I would join in with him. And then he would start singing it, but I would lose the beat. And he would go, no, no, no, do do it again, do it again. And I was like, I don't, it's a commercial. I can't, I don't know how to sing a commercial, you know. It was really fun because we started laughing at the absurdity of two grown men singing that song at the Chili's.
Like, I was laughing at that alone, I thought it was so funny. And then these two guys were somewhat like each other. You know, like you expected Christian to be this kind of like, you know, city worker dude, but then, you know, he had all of these like private issues that came out during lunch. You know, like his mother being ill and stuff like that. Yeah, he overshared just the way Michael overshared. Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Was it just one day of work? Did you guys get it all in one day? I think it was actually. What an epic day. Yeah, we worked our day and we ended up shooting at night thing where we were getting into cars, ain't goodbye. So we were there all day. I remember at the end,
uh, Karel improvised. I don't think they used it on the show. But he went, thanks a lot, Christian, and uh, tell your mother, good luck with her leg or something like that. Because I said, my mother like, I do her one of the improv things. I said, my mother lost her leg diabetes or something like that. But I managed to push on through. And so during one of the improvs when he was leaving, he goes, tell your mother's good love with her leg. You know what, we should remind folks that you and Steve had done seconds to be together, right? In Chicago. And so you had definitely a shorthand with one another when it came to improv, and it was so fun to watch. Yeah, he's really fun to improvise with.
And I had known him for a long time, but like our improv paths, we all started at the same time there, but then I sort of like jumped ahead of people a little bit, because I got hired for the main stage cast at Second City. And then he came in after I got hired. He was hired at the main stage after I went on to Saturday Night Live, but Nancy,
his wife also was hired at SNL. So we all still sort of kept in touch during those years. But the most fun though, I don't know if he's mentioned this, but we did this gig in DC a long time ago with Second City and it was Corral, his wife Nancy, myself, John Glazer, Teresa, Rosenfall. Oh yeah. And Adam McKay, David Keckner. We did a second city show that those guys had written in Chicago, but then we did this improv said it and it was at the Kennedy Center during the summer for like six weeks Wow
We did this thing where we had an improv set after every show and I tell everybody they asked who was best improv group You it was that group of people we were the best improv group group of people. We were the best improv group that I had worked with, like, you know, doing long-form improv and stuff. And the audience, they had not seen it before. So, their minds were blown. They couldn't believe we were like, you make that up, you just made that up. We're like, yeah, we make it up for a long time. That's right. Yeah, it was cool. Those guys are great. It was really great. Oh, man, I wish I could go back and watch that. I'm such a geek for improv.
Yeah. This kind of leads me into my next question, which was that we were kind of part of the same NBC family at the same time, the cast of the office, the cast of SNL. We would hang out a lot together. We would have to do these NBC press events. Our lives are all completely different now. We're not on TV every week anymore. And I was just going to say, if there was a moment that you could go back and relive, what would it be? Would it be the Kennedy Center improv show?
Wow. Moment to go back and re- I think the moment that I love, it has a bunch. Yeah, that's a tough question, you know. Yes, tough one. But I gotta say, maybe the one would Lauren flew me out to New York. And I was just a guest and I, Tom Hanks was the host and they did the five-timers club for the first time. And I was in the office with Lauren during my meeting and then he asked me to read one of the parts in the Five Timers sketch in his office with Paul Simon, Conan O'Brien,
John Loveitz, Ralph Nader. And I was just nerd from Chicago who would, you know, I didn't, it was insane to me, you know, and as Steve Martin was there too, you know, and I was a huge, and still am, a huge Steve Martin fan. And I think in hindsight, I think Lauren was sort of testing me to see if I could handle being around famous people and stuff. But I just remember that whole week that I was there is just being like this magical thing
where I was still in my old life, but my new life was taking me into this new place, you know? Oh, I love that. It was really great. It was that moment of just like holy cow. And I used to always think, I don't know about you guys, but like when I was on the show, there would be weeks in the first three or four weeks
that I was there. I thought somebody from security was gonna come up during the rewrite meetings and say, that dude shouldn't be here. He was a manager of a record store about two years ago. He shouldn't be at the writing table at SNL. A rest room. Yeah, you know me and Brian and Oscar
over there in the accounting department. We had a running joke for years where like any one of us could go at any time. Like, they don't need to be accountants. It's even a joke in the show. We could be replaced. But that is a big accounting department. I love so much just what you said about when the moment where your old life and new life are kind of intersecting, it's so true. It's kind of a surreal moment where you feel this passage of
like, oh my god, but then you go back to your job. I, it's just, yeah. Yeah. What was funny, because I was like in the process of making the most money I'd ever made in my life up to that point. And I was also broke and in debt. Yeah. You know what I mean? Like, within a week, I would have cleared out my debt.
I would have been, you know what I mean? My first check from SNL would have made everything cool. And in the next check would have put me over, you know what I'm saying? Yeah. But yeah, it was broke and had money at the same time. Well, I would love to talk to you guys a little bit about your new movie, Mean Girls. And I got to see the long extended trailer. It looks so fun. Yeah, Tim, you are reprising your role of Principal Duval. I play Katie's mom, Ms. Heron. By the way, does Principal Duval have a first name?
Ooh, that's a good question. I don't think he does. I don't know. I noticed, and busy Phillips is in the movie as well, and I was talking to her about it. All of the adults are just like Ms or Mr and then a last name. They did not bother to give the adults first names. So in my dorky actor prep, I did name Ms. Heron Laura.
So it's just my own personal backstory. It doesn't. Tina Fey know that you named your, your character, Laura? Yes, I told her on set. Yes. So, uh, I didn't know if, uh, Principal DuVal had a first name, or if you, if you had considered one for him. I had not considered one, but you know what?
I, I should look at maybe the old movie or the commercial, because I know that there was like, there were diplomas on my wall behind me. Oh, yeah. So I could probably see, my guess is this is probably Anthony, because there was a play on Anthony in the first movie. Oh, yeah.
I hated my nephew's name. Yeah, I remember. Yeah, he hated that his name was Anthony. Oh, that's a good background catch though. We'll have to go look and see if we can zoom in on your diploma. Yeah, and I will say too, this is my maybe fourth time playing a teacher or educator with the same type of cost costume tie and sweater vest. Gold birch I did it for 10 years. Mean Girls, the first movie, the new mean girls and then school that spin off Goldbirds. I played a principal and now I'm in a new
movie called Dream Scenario with Nicholas Cage and I play a Dean of the College. You were meant to be an education. Creative people only see me as, you know, as their teachers or something. I think it's crazy. Do you remember your character's occupation on the pilot we did, the Gabriel's? Oh! Were you a teacher? You made a big teacher?
I think you were. As you were saying that, I was like, wait, what I think he was a teacher? I think he was a teacher. Oh my god. And I even told my agent and manager at one point, I was like, I can't do any more teacher because I kept getting other requests for roles, even just in episodic things, you know, words like, yeah, he's the principal of the, you know, it is a meeting with him in the PTA. And I'm like, I can't keep doing this
because people are gonna think it's kind of like connection between the things that I've, other shows that I've done, or that I'm not very versatile, you know? So either way, no more fucking principles after. Drinks and air. That ends here, this is it. It is.
2024 is the end of the principal roles. Don't call it to meadows. You heard it here. Anymore. For teachers. I don't play tutors. I don't play teachers. I don't play instructors.
Nothing where I'm giving information to people. So we should share with people that this version of Mean Girls has some musical numbers. Do you sing or dance in the movie because I don't? Ah, that was hoping you did, because I would love to see that. She would have loved to dance. She tapped dances. I can't believe you don't tap dance in this movie, Jenna. I tried. When I was on set I pulled the choreographer aside. We did you tap dancing? I thought maybe I could I don't maybe miss her in
Has a tap number it didn't happen the sound guy hated that moment too He's like what's all that noise over there? You're like, what's all that noise over there? Jennifer Fisher, tap dancing by crap services. Again, here she goes. Actually, I do sing. You do? Oh, that's so exciting. We only had one day where we overlapped filming on this movie.
Yes. I didn't see you sing that day, but I'm very excited to see this now. Yeah, I actually, they have sing that day, but oh, I'm very excited to see this now. Yeah, I actually, they had me come in and redo it recently because obviously, when I did it live, I was flat or something. I don't know what they call it, flat or sharp.
I was one of those things. So I came in and they were like doing that thing of like, hit it with this note here. Here in your note. I'm up here. Yes. You're down here. You're down here. Well Tim, you know, we were in walk-hard together too.
Yes, my favorite. Let me tell you something. Yes. That is the most quoted movie to me. Really? It's a amazing movie. It is one of my, maybe my favorite movie I've ever been in. I haven't seen any girls yet.
Okay, so but I absolutely loved making walk-hard and I love the movie. We had so much fun. We had so much fun. What's the quote you get from that movie? For me, it's, you don't want to know part of this. Do you want to know part of this? Yeah. And then the weed, whole weed run of all the drug
runs, people will say to me, you know, it's not habit forming. I think I want to try it. You don't want no part of this, do it. It takes all of your bad feelings and make them good. Well, I do really want to try. You don't want no part of this. I get that a lot. People love it. And the thing is the musicians also are big fans of that movie. I've had numerous musicians tell me that they just keep it on a loop on their tour business and they quote it. That movie I always tell people was the most fun of all the things I've done. That movie was 30 days, whatever, both just like we have fun.
Laugh so hard. Chris Parnell and Matt Besson. Oh my gosh. Chris Parnell. With those guys too. And I had no Matt Besson forever and had never really hung out with him that much. And then we became really good friends. Even now we're like way closer than we've ever been.
And Chris Parnell, we're less friends. We're less friends. Screech at Chris. Chris reached out to town. I don't know. Our birthdays on the same day. So every year, we text each other. We call each other Mr. Like Mr. Parnell. Busy Phillips and I have the same birthday. We do similar thing. We always text each other on our birthdays. Brian, Franston and I have the same birthday.
Do you text each other? No, we don't. No. Come on, Brian, step up. Brian, this is the year. No more educational roles for Tim, and this year, you're texting Brian. OK.
That sounds good. Yeah. Well, you know, Tim, on walk-hard, they had me take singing lessons, and they had me record my voice. And then the director, Jake Kaz, came up to me a few weeks later and he was like, you know what, Jenna, you're a fantastic actress. Uh-oh. And you're so funny in the film.
But we're going to go ahead and just replace your voice with the woman who did the practice track. Um, but great, great effort. We're still going to use your face. Yeah. Don't get me wrong now. Your lip syncing is really strong. But so maybe the mean girls people heard and maybe the word without saying I don't know it was the most awkward conversation oh that's so funny Jake was sleeping in his bed one day it was like
ring hello hi to mean girls people why did you tell us she's terrible I am in a couple of musical numbers and mean girls, which was I- In the real one. Yeah, I'm very excited about it because you know they're all dancing or singing around me. So I got to observe it. They're like stay out of this. They're like just standing there. Please just stand on your mark, please. Will you please stand there and watch us be talented?
Yes. I mean, amazing. Here's my moment. I had to sing Little Drummer Boy in front of the whole bullpen of the office. I remember that. And Harold Rames was directing. And I kept losing the tune. He came up and he was like,
it's little drummer boy. You know what I mean? Like, he didn't say it, he was so kind, but he implied like, how can you lose the beat on little drummer boy? The rap of Bob Bob. What else you look at? That's it.
But I told him I was like, you're old, I can't do this, I can't sing. And he's like, but you will. The single patient is in the lyrics, okay? You understand? The single patient is in the lyrics. No, I was like so embarrassing. You guys should the three of us do a musical.
A musical. The three of us. Like Tim, you will shine. You will shine. In our three person musical, you will be... I would stand out. You will. I would stand out.
Finally. It will be s***. Unfortunately though, I started kind of pitching on it and you will need to play a teacher. A teacher? It's an eight grade teacher. If I can sing and play a teacher, forget it. I'm in. Okay. If we mention there's not a lot of money, but it doesn't matter. Doesn't matter for the art. It was so fun. Thank you so You guys for coming on office ladies. Yeah. Oh, it's my pleasure.
Well, you know, I listened to the show obviously, but when you were on the set, you told me to listen because I was Steven, it's just something nice about me. And it was very nice. And I played it for my kids. It's just a really. Yeah, he said I was a great improviser. kids just did really yeah he said I was a great improviser and it was like one of the things I'm very proud of being you know good at so it was nice. Oh I love that. All that makes us so happy. I would also say about him that he is also quite average at improv. Quite average.
Can he play that for his kids? Yeah. Can he Can he play that for his kids? Yeah. Can he play the play that for his kids? Steve Tim was on office ladies and we have a clip you might want for your kids. He says you're a... You're quite average. Quite average. Keep at it buddy.
He's great. He's great. Tim before we let you go, what are you up to now? Well, actually, I am about to head out to London in Barcelona to do some long-form improv with some friends of mine. Matt Walsh from Bright Citizens Brigade. Love Matt.
Yeah. K&I and Joe Canali and Brad Morris, two friends of ours from Chicago. We got invited to come to London. We got a couple of more European invitations, so we're gonna do this other trip again, but yeah, January we're gonna be out there. It's gonna be great.
Okay, this great. This great, all the details we'll put it in our office ladies pod stories, so folks can come find y'all. Okay, I will. Well, everybody, please go watch our movie Mean Girls. It comes out this Friday, January 12th. It's your last chance to see Tim Meadows
in an educator role, so take advantage of that. And it's a chance to see me standing my other, singing dance around me. Cee-jana, stand in one spot. Oh, I can't wait. I can't wait. You got me crying. I'm crying over here. Oh.
Thank you for having me. Yes, absolutely. We are back. My heart is full. Tim is so wonderful. I love him. What a treat! Alright, before we get into this episode, I feel like we need a little call sheet tidbit. Already? Already from Steve Burgess, I got all the call sheets. And I have to share this just right away. Y'all, it was the week of August 6th when we shot this episode. Monday, the first day of filming was the coolest day of the week. It was 98 degrees.
Wow. We're getting a triple digits real fast. Yeah, this was a hot week, and this is gonna come up later when I discuss some location challenges based on this heat Well, let's get into this cold open. It's a personal favorite of mine. It's the chore wheel. Jenna, have you made a chore wheel in your real life?
No, you would think I had. Chore chart. Chore anything. Chore lists. I bet there's chore lists. Yeah, we have a whiteboard. Okay, right that counts. That's a chor- board? Chor- board. Okay. I really regret not keeping the chor- wheel. Oh, the chor- wheels. I wanted the mini- wheel, I wanted the bigger wheels. I begged Phil Shea for them.
But there were not multiples of these chor- wheels. There was one of each, and he had to put them in storage in case we ever used them again on the show. You know, there's a possibility that choreweel could come back. It could have been a thing. Yeah, so I couldn't take it. And I just wish I would have remembered when the show was over.
That's what I'm kicking myself about. Yeah, the mini choreweel, like sitting on a bookshelf, would be amazing. Right. I did see online this young Gallant College made herself a mini chore wheel, like Pam's for her dorm room. People are so crafty. Well, I guess we should describe what happened. Yes.
Pam gets to work and there's like trash everywhere. Oh, it's disgusting. I guess the janitor of the building is on vacation, and Dwight isn't gonna hire a temporary replacement, so everybody has to do their own cleaning up. And no one is doing it. So Pam makes her chore wheel? Yes!
But nobody likes it because it doesn't spin. I would like to point out that Pam has fancy nail polish again. Yes, this time it's a burgundy color. Mm-hmm. Also at 16 seconds, I really enjoyed the detail fancy nail polish again. Yes. This time it's a burgundy color. Also at 16 seconds, I really enjoyed the detail that Dwight is sitting at his desk and not participating in the conference for a day.
Yes. He's watching from afar. Would you like a breakdown of Pam's original choreo wheel? Sure. Here are the chores. Clean restrooms, water plants, replace lights, wash windows, mug duty, vacuum, clean kitchenette, sweep entrance, empty trash, dust off machines, and clean break room. The second chore
wheel has the exact same categories, but it just spins. Yes, no one was impressed. And the final chore wheel spins and has all new categories, which are bankrupt. Go home now, exclamation point. Manager for an hour, candy bar, punch in the gut, ten bucks, creed's choice, warehouse vacation, no internet, tiny wheel, Stanley gets your lunch, and spin again.
Well, that is certainly a much more fun wheel. Yeah, it is. There's ups and downs on that one. 10 bucks. I wanna get that one. But the original one is all chores. And when Kevin spins, it gets mug duty. Everyone's like, this thing sucks.
Yeah. We got a fan question from Maddie R. and Dallas, Texas, who said, in the cold open when Kevin's spin lands on mug duty, Pam explains that this means he has to clean all the mugs in the sink. I have never worked in an office, so maybe I'm wrong, but isn't it weird that people don't clean their own mugs? Is this something that the custodial staff would do? Why can't everyone just wash their own mug for the time being? Well, lady, this took me down a rabbit hole.
I Googled mug cleaning culture in offices. You did, kids. I did. I Googled, what are the top 10 chores people hate doing the most? In offices or in life. In life. Why don't we start with your mug cleaning? And then I'll tell you the top 10 most hated chores according to the internet. Great.
All right, well, I thought about this because when we worked at the Ear Wolf offices, I would always have the instinct to clean my own mug, but I noticed that it was the culture of the office to just leave your mugs and glasses in the sink and it was part of the front desk. The person who worked the front desk would always clean all the mugs. We just had community mugs and glasses in the sink and it was part of the front desk. The person who worked the front desk would always clean all the mugs. We just had community mugs.
I don't know if people brought their own in, but I just always use the community mug, which never really bothered me until I was digging deeper into this basic office coffee mug etiquette. And I found out of really disturbing fact that I can't unthink now. About coffee mugs? Uh-huh. At work? Uh-huh. I found a study that was done by total jobs that found that one in five communal office mugs contain fecal matter. What? Because 25% of people don't wash their hands after they go to the bathroom. Ah! Yeah. Oh my God, we have to bring our own mugs everywhere.
That's what it said. It said you really need to bring your own mug and wash your own mug. And then take it home. Or bring it back. Or like, hide it in your desk. Put it in your drawer. Yeah. I feel like-
Just disgusting. I know. And this feels like a time when I have to remind everybody that I always wash my hands after number two And I always wash my hands. Oh because of the one time space I just sometimes don't wash my hands every time I tinkle in my own house. Okay, that's all But I'm not putting any fecal matter on any mugs I just want to get that out there and clear that up for anybody who's got to come for me in the comments
I just want to get that out there and clear that up for anybody who's got to come for me in the comments. This study also found that the average office desk has 400 times more bacteria than a toilet seat. So if you're going to eat lunch at work, you're going to want to wipe that space down before you eat. And you should also wash your reusable water bottle every single day. So like, don't leave it on your desk overnight and then come into work and just start drinking out of it again because it's not sanitary and the water will breed bacteria and you could get sick. Oh, I do that all the time. I know. I just leave a water bottle on my desk and I just pick right back up with it. I know. You're drinking some bacteria. Okay. But you're not drinking people. I am not. You are not drinking fecal batter. I am not you are not
Wow, okay, I'm gonna look at the communal coffee mugs differently anywhere I go now Yep, I'm using one right now Well before we get to my top 10 chores people hate I want to share Pam's talking head and the chore that Meredith gets Hmm, Pam says she's been through several stages of development of the chore wheel with her team. Who's her team? There's no team.
I think that's herself. I'm like, Pam, there's no team. You're trying to sound fancy. And she's added incentives. We've talked about it. $10 candy bar. And then Meredith gets tiny wheel. And everyone starts cheering.
Pam spends it and it lands on toilets. And they're like, woohoo! And Meredith was like, yay, toilets! She seems so happy to clean toilets, but let me tell you, according to the internet, cleaning the bathroom slash toilets is number one on the chores people hate. It's one of my favorite chores.
Really? I love all water-based cleaning. Bathrooms, kitchen, sink, dishes. I like that you've given it a category. Yeah. Water-based cleaning. If I'm using like water, you like it. I like it.
Number two is washing the dishes. You probably like it. It's water-based. I don't mind it. Number three, cleaning the stove top and oven. Okay, I don't care for that. Yeah. It's very greasy business.
And also it's like a lot of little corner. Oh, nooks. Number four, doing laundry and ironing. Oh, that's a big sigh. You don't like doing laundry. It depends on the day. Okay. Dusting.
Hate. Hate dusting. Move it up to number one. For me. Number six, sweeping and vacuuming. Number two. I don't mind it at all. I love to vacuum.
It's great. Like, yeah, I like to see the grooves in the carpet. I don't know, it's so fun. I hate dry cleaning, dusting vacuuming. Don't care for it. Okay, this is your category, water-based or dry cleaning. Next up is mopping. It's the one wet activity I don't like.
Okay, you've got one. Oh, next one. Grocery shopping and cooking. Yeah, these are things people don't like doing, guys. Number nine, cleaning the windows. I love cleaning windows. I don't mind it. You know why? It's like an immediate result.
I think that's what I like. And lastly, cleaning the gutters. I don't want to clean the gutters. Josh cleans the gutters. I don't want to clean the gutters. I also can't reach even on our tallest ladder. Sure. It's so interesting that that one was included. You know what? They didn't include on that list. Maybe this just falls under laundry, but this would be real high on my list of things I hate doing. Sheets. Yeah.
Putting sheets on a bed, making a bed from scratch. I don't mind making a bed that already has covers on it. Yeah. I don't mind that. I don't mind. Like the fitted sheet doesn't bother me. I'm very lucky because I feel like Lee and I we balance each other. Like the things I hate, he doesn't mind. Yeah. If we're going to clean up the house, he does all the vacuuming. He just like gets on it. And I'm happy to do the bathrooms. It's interesting. We never talked about it. It just sort of happened.
Same with Josh and I. We just sort of found our strengths or something. Yeah. Just leaned into them. Exactly. Well, this cold open is going to end with Meredith trotting away, very excited to clean some toilets. Then we're going to zoom in on a little rat.
That's walking around Dwight and Jim's desks. This rat was of course from Bob Dunns. Where do they keep all these animals? They have dogs, cats, porcupines, rats, squirrels, where are they? I'd like to see them. Do they live together? Bob Dunn has a farm.
That's what I like to think. I don't know, it's so interesting to me. Anyway, Steve Burgess said he thinks that the rat cost about $200 a day. We had to hire it for two days. It needed its training day and a shooting day. And we also had to pay for the trainer plus transportation. So in the end, it was about $1,500 to get that shot of the rat.
That rat shot. In the trash. Well, you know, there was part of me when we saw that little rat that really wanted Aaron or Darryl to have a name for it, because we know they've been feeding mice for years. Maybe they know this, dude. Yes, maybe Darryl has a little top hat for it. Yeah. Oh, that would have been cute.
Well, the show is going to open. We're at Jim and Pam's house. They're loading up the car, Cece's playing in the front yard. Looks like she has her little snuggle blanket on her head. She has the same little lovey that my kids used. Oh yeah! So cute! Well, per the call sheet this day, the high was 101 degrees.
It was Tuesday. We also had a table read this day for Andy's ancestry. And I thought you might like to have a little get to know your cast and crew moment. Oh! Alright, sounds good. I have two for this episode. First one up was Edward Nielsen III from our camera and electrical department. Here are things you didn't know about Ed Nielsen.
It says, oh, where to begin, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, four dots. Ed speaks orcish. Mrs. having no responsibility in his childhood and looks forward to doing nothing on the weekends. When asked about time travel, he said it is BS and for Trekkies. And of course, my folks that love Lord of the Rings, you know orkish is the primary language of the orks. Oh, I didn't know that. It is the main language of the horde. So it's made up. It's made up language. Oh, I didn't know it. When you said it. Okay, you had a blank look on your face. I was like, oh, I this must be some sort of Nordic language. I didn't know what it was. I was like,
so impressive. I didn't know he spoke that. I would have read that and then gone up to him and be like, oh my God, you speak this, where is it from? What is Orkish? Yes. I'll have you know, Angela, we shot this scene first up in the day. It was very, very early to avoid the heat. We're going to see Jim in a talking head.
He's all dressed up. So is Pam. He explains they are going to Roy's wedding at 8 a.m. Yeah. We got a fan mail flurry about this, Ange. Oh, yeah. People want to know why would Pam and Jim go to Roy's wedding? Why would they even be invited? Okay, well, there was a deleted storyline
in last week's episode, New Guys, right? Right. And it sets up this Roy's wedding storyline. I really debated about sharing it last week, but then I thought, I don't want to give away any spoilers. So I'm going to share it this week. Okay. Jim and Pam have a scene where they discuss what they're buying Roy for his upcoming wedding. Oh, yeah. And they're at their desk. They're looking at the wedding registry website. And then there was a Pam talking head about it. Let's hear it. Roy Anderson, my former
fiance, is getting married unless his bride pulls what I'm sure they call a Pam or that bitch Pam. And wait, there was a candy bag alt that was a must shoot. So you did say this to the camera. Here was an alt talking head. Pam would have said, Roy Anderson, my former fiance is getting married. What do you get for a man whose butt you've seen thousands of times? Okay.
And I zoomed in on the wedding registry website. Uh huh. They decide to get Roy a ladle, right? Like a fancy ladle. Okay. And Pam's like, that doesn't seem like a lot. Jim's like, I don't know, get him the spoon too. I looked, the ladle cost $174.
Whoa. Yeah. Well, my question is, how big is this ladle? Because that gift that they're carrying out of Jim and Pam's house, that box is very long. I know, I thought that too. I'm like, what is that the ladle, the spoon, clearly they went another way? Well, we got another fan question
from Kyle C. and Stockton, California, who said, a wedding on a morning of a work day at 8 a.m. Huh. Huh. Well, Kyle, I want you to know that Jenna and I have a mutual friend who got married very early on a Saturday morning and did a breakfast reception. And I went up to our friend at the reception and I was like, this is so pretty. I've never been to a wedding this early.
And our friend leaned into me and said, eggs are cheap. Well, give any names, but you know what, it can be a very cost effective wedding, which we're going to find out soon that Roy didn't need a cost effective wedding. So it does beg the question, why is Roy's wedding at 8 AM on a week day? Yeah, we never get an answer. But on her way to the car, Pam has grabbed a banana because she's pretty sure that Roy is not going to have great food.
He's probably going to serve hot dogs. They're being like snarky about the wedding. Like what is this thing going to be? It's Roy. I know, but Pam's like, I planned a wedding with Roy. He wanted hot dogs. Jim's looked at cameras like, again, how weird is this? So I'm going to my wife's ex-fiancé's wedding.
Yeah, Pam planned a whole wedding with this person. Now we're gonna head over to Dunder Mifflin and Pete and Clark have arrived to the office. They tend to do things in Unison all the time. Have you noticed? They arrive at exactly the same time. They take a break at the same time. Yeah.
These guys are joined at the hip. It's interesting. But it doesn't seem like by choice. Like it doesn't seem like Pete wants to be joined with who are. With who are? No. Aaron has one piece of mail for the customer service department and she's going to give it to Pete this time.
She's dividing it up. Yeah. There's a little banter between Pete and Aaron and gosh, the way he looks at her, he's so charmed by the fact that sometimes she writes nice letters to customer service departments. He's like, that's the sweetest thing. I know. It's cute. I like cute. It's a little bit of a meat cute. It's a little bit of a meat cute and I'm just gonna say right now, I like how Pete looks at her. Yeah, I do. Yeah.
I think they want me to root for this romance and I already am. I'm already on board. We just don't want Erin and Andy to end up together. I think we're gonna bring anyone in. We're like, okay. Well, you guys will remember that Nelly says, her real specialty is special projects.
And she's got a new special project. Her new special project is the launch of Operation Gift Back. She's passing out flyers to everyone. It's her new charity initiative. Andy has rejected all of her special project proposals, but this one is for charity. So she'd like to see him piss on this one. She's going to address the bullpen and say there's $4,000
to give to charity, and they get to pick the charities. So she wants everyone to sort of make suggestions. Yeah. Stanley is going to suggest the American Diabetes Foundation. Angela finds this to be a selfish choice. Yes. He has diabetes.
Creed wants to help Jimmy Carter build gnomes. Does that just get tossed out there and no one reacts to it? No one reacted. Toby has an idea, but he gets interrupted. And finally, Dwight announces he's not gonna participate due to the lack of evidence that charity works. Nelly tells Dwight the participation is mandatory.
So he says, fine, I pick the global relief foundation. By the way, it was recently discovered to be a front for the Taliban. And everyone's like, oh, Dwight. I know. I'd like to point out that Nelly has a beautiful bouquet of roses on her desk. Oh, I don't know why.
Do they compliment her fancy chair? She doesn't have her fancy chair anymore. Oh, no. I guess she had to take fancy chair? She doesn't have her fancy chair anymore. Oh, no. I guess she had to take it home because Andy doesn't have it either. Mm-hmm. I know. Well, now we are gonna go to Roy's wedding.
It looks lovely. It's like a garden wedding outside. Yes, I guess it's in his backyard. Bob Vance and Phyllis are there. Darryl and Val are there. Yeah. Roy's gonna greet Darryl. He's happy.
He looks great. Yeah. Super handsome David are there. Yeah. Roy's gonna greet Darryl. He's happy. He looks great. Yeah. Super handsome David Denman. Yeah. There's a tray of mimosas going by. And Jim and Pam are gonna arrive. Pam's still eating her banana.
They're walking up the driveway and they're greeted. By a waiter, he's got mimosas on a silver tray. This waiter has maybe my favorite line of the entire episode. It's some real good like side eye snark. Mm, he says, would you like me to take your peel? Mm, I just want to know. But it was really funny. We got a lot of mail about this opening scene.
Fan question from Alice in W and Winnipeg, who said, do Jim and Pam live really close to Roy? Why was Pam still eating her banana when they arrived to his house? Or maybe Pam just savors eating a banana? Oh, this is like some deep, deep leaning into banana time. Like what is your banana clock? Well, Alice, and I'll tell you, in real life,
Pam and Jim's house is an entire day away from Roy's house because we shot these on different days. I'll tell you, in real life, Pam and Jim's house is an entire day away from Roy's house. Oh. We shot these on different days. And also, when Pam is leaving her house, she hasn't started eating her banana yet. That was a choice I made because I knew I was gonna have to still be eating it when I arrived. So I think we were thinking that she just waited
to eat it in the car. By the way, that's also why I gave myself the business of fudzing with my earring as I walked out of a house. I wanted you to believe like maybe I got my car and still fudzing with myself. I believed it. You sold it. Thank you. Thank you.
I ate a banana on my drive in this morning. Yeah. I have about a half hour drive and I only ate half my banana. But you always only eat half your food. That's true. Yeah, you fill up fast. I can't, you've a tiny stomach.
I can't really be part of this banana time conversation. Well, speaking of locations, Roy's house was filmed at a house on Ventura Canyon in Sherman Oaks, and Steve Burgess reminded me that we ran into a number of logistical problems at this location, many based on the extreme heat. Angela, do you have a temperature for me? I do per the call sheet. The day you filmed these scenes was Thursday, August 9th, and the
high was 103 degrees. Yeah. It was hot and it was sunny. So we had to bring in a condor. Not the bird. Oh, the crane. Mm-hmm. To try to shade it. So we had to bring in a condor, not the bird. Oh, the crane. To try to shade it. Yeah. We had to put up this huge, it's called a fly swatter in the biz, little biz lingo for you.
And it's just like a huge piece of sherry silk material. They hang it really high over the location so that it lets in light and it's not like too low on us, I guess, but every time the sun would move, we would have to move the fly swatter. So it would have to be like, oh my gosh, it's like a big thing to move, it's an enormous crane. Yeah. We also had to move it from the front of the house to the back of the house, and it was really time-consuming, and Steve Burgess sent me pictures of it. So you can put them in our Instagram stories. Oh, I will.
We also got a fan question from Marissa D and San Jose, California, who said, Jenna, how many times did you have to eat that banana? I hope only once. Marissa, it wasn't only once. How many times? It was a lot of times. That's all I remember. When I watched the scene, I was like, I ate so much banana, but I was really committed to it. But I also had a spit bucket. So any banana that was
left when the scene was over, I got to spit it out, you know. Yeah. So I probably ate half as much bananas. It seems like I ate. You're always thankful for a spit bucket when you're doing scenes like this. I mean, remember how sick Reign got when he had to eat all the bananas? Because he didn't spit them out. I know. You know, bananas are a binding food. They will mess you up if you go too hard. Yeah. You shouldn't eat that much banana, you know,
in one sitting. All right, next up, van question from Kaden M in Warrenville, Illinois. Jenna, was it scripted that you put the other half of the banana on the plate or was that an ad lib? It's one of the funniest moments in the whole show. I agree.
I agree. When the waiter says, can I take your peel and she flops it on the tray and grabbed a mimosa. I was like, oh, I like this Pam. This Pam is ready to take on this wedding. Well, this was a scripted moment and here's what it said. It was scripted that Pam quote,
awkwardly stuffs the rest of the banana in her mouth and gives the peel to the caterer. The caterer, by the way, it was played by David Britz and we had a good time. He was great. Well, during this banana business, Jim is gonna get a phone call. He's been getting lots of phone calls.
He's been shady about him too. He jokes to Pam that it's his ex-fiancé, and then he has a talking head, where he shares that he has started a new business with his college friend and Pam doesn't know. Well, actually, he told Pam, but then they decided no, but then he decided yes anyway. So he thinks there's going to be another conversation coming.
Oh, big sigh. Yeah. So he's now just shared with the camera crew of this documentary. Pam's going to have to watch this someday that he has gone behind her back and is keeping the secret. And now a lot of people know but Pam. Yeah. Well now we're going to see a scene where Jim approaches Roy. Yeah. I'm calling this scene snark alert.
Well it's good that you did, Lady, because I thought there was some snark and I went to the shooting draft and it says as Jim approaches in parentheses, a little snarky. Oh! Uh-huh! Look! Snarky! In the shooting draft, when Jim says, is it almost time to cut the pancake or what?
What a dick. What a snarky thing to say. Who is Jim season 9? Who is this guy? Ah! Roy couldn't be lovelier. He's so gracious. He said, you know what?
We appreciate everyone coming out so early. It's just been so nice. And also, listen, he wouldn't have met Lara if it hadn't been for Jim, right? Yeah. And then Roy does get a dig in. He says, really dodged a bullet on that one, am I right? Haha. Yeah.
But then, all of a sudden, we're going to find out that Roy has a $50,000 car. Well, wait. He started a gravel company and it just took off. And then Roy's brother Kenny walks up and says to Roy, hey, bro, stop wasting time with this haircut and points to Jim. And that's when he shares that he has a $50,000 sports car. I know. Once you know Kenny's scripted line was, stop wasting time with this limp dick.
Hi, that's making me love. That's really funny. We had a fan question to Angela from Shelby A and Huntsville, Alabama, who said, we see Roy and Jim interact at Roy's wedding. Was there anything scripted between Pam and Roy? I'm so curious what they would have said to each other after all those years. Well Shelby, I was really curious about this too.
I went to the shooting draft. There are no scenes with Roy and Pam, but there might be a reason why she never makes it to Roy because she gets some serious shade from his parents. So in the shooting draft it said, Pam stands awkwardly with two drinks. She is clearly heading back to Jim when Roy's parents stop her. And I think you got to hear it. It's in deleted scenes. She gets some serious shade. We just love Laura. I couldn't imagine a better daughter-in-law. It's great to see Roy so happy.
Oh, he's the happiest he's ever been. How wonderful. Laura is really easy to get along with. And she's loyal. Which is what I think Roy needs. Nice to see you again, Pam. Thank you. Be well.
And so, Pam is just left there standing awkwardly with two drinks. And she never makes it over to Jim and Roy. So maybe that's why there's no scene between Pam and Roy. Oh, I remember shooting that scene. That was so fun. I love the dad as he walks away. He just goes, be well.
Yeah. So now you thought the biggest creeper Dunder Mifflin had left. Yeah, well we said goodbye to Robert California. We thought all of the perversion left with him, but we were wrong and oh were we wrong. Clark is just as bad as Robert California. Yeah, I mean, dare I say he's worse.
Yeah, he's in the break room. He and Pete are side by side per usual, and they're having a snack. Aaron is seated at a different table. Clark is gonna take a phone call. Clearly the person on the other line is asking if he knows anyone who could be a newscaster. Because you know, that's how you become a newscaster,
everybody. Yeah, that's how it happens in the break room at the paper company. It doesn't require a journalism degree. No, Yeah, that's how it happens in the break room at the paper company. It doesn't require a journalism degree. No, no, no. It just requires a creep making a fake e-phone call to try to get a girl back to his house. What a creep. Yeah.
Pete doesn't like this. No. He has a frown. He's also drinking out of a hers potato chip mug. Oh. Little shout out to hers. Yeah. Yeah, Clark convinces Aaron to make this audition tape, right?
Yeah, come to his house. Yeah, maybe you have a few different wardrobe looks, some lipstick, some wine to loosen up. Yeah. Pete has a talking head where he says, you know what, I'm not friends with Clark, he's just the douche sitting next to me at the office. Yeah, Aaron says she never thought about being more than a receptionist. That's
just the ad that she answered. What if she had answered an ad for another job like CEO or a brain surgeon? Yeah. She could have been either of those. Yeah. Well, listen, this might be a good place to tell anybody who is an aspiring actor or on air personality that you should never go to an audition in someone's home. It doesn't happen that way. And you know what? It seems obvious, but actually when I first came to LA, there were a lot of what looked like legitimate auditions in like the LA weekly that happened to take place at people's
houses. And I had to have someone tell me not to do that. Yeah. Oh, for sure. I remember there was like a flyer like I'm making an independent movie, holding auditions, but they were like at his garage at his house. You know, and you're like, oh, well it's independent. Maybe they're on a budget. Right. Maybe they're working out of their home for this project. No, don't go. I mean, don't go to anyone's house. Listen, we already told the story of what happened when I showed up for the international Spice Girls commercial in the Geist condo
Right. Yes, Jenna. Okay, so Unfortunately Aaron doesn't have anyone cluing her in. Well, we'll get to it. Pete's gonna try I have something from deleted scenes, but I'm gonna share it later when it happens Why don't we take a break and I'll look forward to hearing that. Okay. We are back and Roy is going to toast his bride. They're so happy. Yes, his wife, Laura, was played by Sarah Chase. And guess what? He has a surprise for her. He does, you know? Laura thought he was taking boxing lessons, but guess what he was doing the whole time?
Taking piano lessons, so he could serenade her on their wedding day. Yes, he starts to sing, She's Got Away by Billy Joel. Pam and Jim do not know what to make of this. Phyllis and Bob make out. They make out hardcore. It did say in the shooting draft that Darryl wipes a tear from his eye. Aww.
He's so happy for his buddy. Per the call sheets, the piano scene was filmed on Friday, August 10th, and the high this day was also 103. Well, we got a fan question from Veronica L. in Illinois who said, did David Deadman play the piano in the wedding reception scene?
No, Veronica, he's faking. Mm-hmm. He played the first couple of notes when we're close up on his hands and we pull back, but then you'll notice the camera never shows his hands again. He was pretending and an actual piano player by the name of Matthew Enkst was playing another
piano off camera so that David could sing along. And they met for a little piano rehearsal that morning at 7 in the morning and that's when they taught David how to play those opening notes. And I was there for that and it was very, very charming. You know, I was just so excited to have David back. He was one of my best friends from the early days of shooting, and we'd lost touch a little bit after we weren't seeing each other all the time. I spent most of this wedding, ironically, with Roy.
With Roy as am. Catching up with your friend, David. Completely. We also had a really fun fan theory from Nikita C in Sydney, Australia, who said, did Daryl teach Roy the piano? Because as Roy sits down to play, Darrell is the one to call out and encourage him. What do you ladies think?
Well, I love that idea. Me too. I do. And also, in the shooting draft, it had how proud Darrell was and he's tearing up. Yeah, I like to believe that he was sneaking off to learn piano from Darrell. Well, I like to believe that he was speaking off to learn piano from Darryl. Well, I think it's time for another
get to know our cast and crew moment from the call sheet. This is about our department head makeup artist, LeVern, Carcousey Milazo, things you didn't know about LeVern. LeVern speaks Italian. The prettiest place she has ever been is the Maldeves. When she was in school, she wanted to be an archaeologist, and her first encounter with the film and TV world was on a non-union, Prince video.
Her favorite thing to do on the weekend is not set an alarm. Ah, I love these tips. I do too. I hope they're interesting to other people who don't know these people, but I'm like, huh, I love knowing, living in a little better. I also love that there's a pattern to the questions. How many languages do you speak? What's a place that you've been to that you love? Yeah. And then also, when did you first come to the film and TV industry?
And then what do you like to do on the weekend? I like this range of questions. It's a really good set of questions. Maybe we should be incorporating these into our interviews. Interviews. Interviews. Yes. Oh, noted. I think we do it.
Jim and Pam are shook up by the wedding. I mean, talk about mouth a game. Yes. When Roy starts playing the piano and singing, Pam is like, what? The whole point of this storyline, and it's interesting because talk about digital clutter, I put Roy's wedding into my email
because I was looking for tidbits from Steve Burges, and I found these old emails between me, Greg, Allison Silverman, and John Krasinski, where we were pitching different ideas. And this idea that somehow Jim and Pam would run into Roy and he would have bettered himself like that he had grown in his time away from Pam. This was really important because it was supposed to of course further highlight how the same Jim and Pam are. How like growth seems to have alluded them. Not only that, but how they're disconnected. Roy and Laura seem very connected.
Yes. I do want to point out one thing in the car, which I find curious, at nine minutes and 24 seconds, you can see C.C.'s car seat in the car makes sense. These things live in a car, but also Phillips pumpkin seat. Usually you leave the pumpkin seat at home, right? It just clicks into the base. Yeah. That's how we did it. We had a base in each car, but the pumpkin seat goes outside. Yeah. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It Pam's car. That's right. Well, you know this car scene Pam is going to ask Jim to tell her something she doesn't
know about him. There was more to this moment, it's in deleted scenes and I want you to hear how this conversation ended. Oh, the record I like knowing everything about you. It's nice. Totally agree. We know each other inside now. No surprises.
Yeah, she says no surprises. And then his phone starts to buzz. And he doesn't answer it. He clicks, you know how you can kind of like make it stop buzzing. And then they just ride in silence. The moment was heavy, it was thick. I've been rewatching Breaking Bad. You have from the beginning. Okay.
I had this theory that Breaking Bad is the best pilot ever made. And you know, I got sick a couple weeks ago. I was laid up for like two weeks. And I was like, for like two weeks, and I was like, what am I gonna watch? I spent two days watching Lawn Order reruns, and I was like, I think I need something with like more of an arc.
You needed a break from gung, gung, yeah. So I was like, I'm gonna see. Is breaking bad the best pilot ever made? It is. It's incredible. Then I got hooked. Now I'm all the way almost at the end of season three, but you know, a big plot line is Walter White
and his burner phone. Yeah. And it's always buzzing. Yeah. In those early seasons and his wife is like, what's going on? What's up with the second cell phone? Yeah.
The second cell phone. Mmm. Are the calls you're not taking in your partner's presence? Listen, all that says it all. If the phone is ringing and they purposely don't answer it, who's on the other end of that call? That's right. You're either having an affair or you're making meth or you have started a business with your friend and you're not telling your wife.
Those are the three things. Back at Dundra Mifflin in the kitchen, Jim and Pam are still continuing this, like tell me something I don't know about you. And then Jim's like, oh, remember the story about how my brothers tricked me into thinking they won the lottery, but Pam already knew that one. And then Angela Bragg's that the senator is always surprising her.
I thought Oscar did such a great job in that moment. I had to mimic it because I was like, that was so good. I thought it was so good how he just kept choking down his coffee. It was such good acting. I loved it. Have you ever played this game with Josh, where you say, like, tell me something I don't know about you? Have you ever played this game? No, where you say, like, tell me something I don't know about you? Have you ever played this game? No, because Josh doesn't want to know.
He doesn't want to know things he doesn't already know about you. Yeah. This is very funny. Yeah, he's just like, I don't need to know anything about past relationships. I just need to live in the here and now with you. Lee and I like to play this game sometimes. If we have a date night, we'll be like, like okay we're not allowed to talk about the kids, we're not allowed to talk about school emails, right, right, or any house improvements or any chores
no schedule. Let's be adults together. So I'll say tell me a story I've never heard before. Yeah. And it it often ends up being something rather interesting. I have to say it's a fun little game. It's not working for Jim and Pam, though. Well, Nelly is going to approach Dwight now. Nelly says, look, if you support the Taliban abroad, you have to be willing to live by their rules here. And she wants that in writing,
and she hands him a contract, which he signs willingly. Dwight then has a talking head where he says, he feared Nelly had a plan, but the ridiculous font tells him otherwise. Then it cuts to Nelly's talking head and she says, when you use a ridiculous font, no one thinks you have a plan. Well, this made me curious about fonts. Oh! I went online in according to 99designs.com. Here's what makes a good font. Oh! Okay. Even kerning?
What's a kern? Exactly. What is kerning? Kerning is the space between two characters. Two little space and the font is unreadable because the letters are smushed together. Too much space and it's hard to tell whether the space is meant to separate letters or words. Oh, that's the Kern. Even Kurning. The Kern is the space between... The Space.
Oh, I want to use that. I want to like look at someone's handwriting and say, oh, you have beautiful Kurning. Yes. The next one is consistency. For example, Futura and Helvechia are two examples of fonts that are easy to read because of their kerning and the consistency of the letters. Okay. And if you're wondering what consistency means, it means like, if you have a font for the letter A and that has serifs, you expect the letter B to have serifs too and so on from there. If you're wondering what a serif is.
A serif is the marker line that can sometimes appear at the end of a character's stroke. Ah, I think I'm picturing a serif. Okay. Then you want balance. You want a blend of thick and thin, heavy and light. That's another component of a good font. And lastly, it must be legible. I have a question for you. Yes. Do you have a favorite font? I like the sand syrup typefaces. You know? I think the one I use the most is maybe Verdana. What about you?
Well, for a very long time, I was a Times New Roman. That is on the list of worst fonts. I have moved to Calibri. Calibri's good. That's when my document is printed in right now. It's printed in Calibri 18. I also like Calibri too. That is also a sans-serif font.
It is? Yes. Oh. What is sans means without in French? So what is Serif? What is it without? A theme with sans serif typepaces are they're very clean and minimal. They look a little bit more modern. If a font has a Serif, it has like the finishing of a stroke. You know what's a font that uses Serif's is times New Roman. Oh, yeah. Okay.
Also, this website said Garamond is a good one. Oh, I've used it before, but. And according to several websites, I mean, this one made the list on many websites. One of the most horrible fonts is Joker Men. I have to look at it. I'm so sorry. I can put it in stories too. I need to see it.
Oh! Oh! It's horrible! It looks like... Oh! This looks like what Nelly used. It's awful. It looks like the letters have a disease. It's so busy. Doesn't it? It's so busy. Yeah. It looks like a plant, the Venus fly trap. If you took a Venus fly trap and turned it into letters, that's what this looks like. Yes to me. Yes.
Well, Joker Man is not popular. I'm so sorry to the person who invented the Jokerman font. Sorry, sorry. You tried hard, but I think you wanted to edit. You did too much. Yeah. Take one thing away. Our three. Three things away. Angela, that was all very interesting. You know, I found it so interesting, just the science behind how we relate to the written characters. The door that's opening for me now is who invents fonts and how do you get them like widely used? Who's doing it?
What is the font industry? Yeah. How do you get paid for that? Who comes up with this list about even kerning? Yeah, that's gonna keep me up at night now. Sorry. Sorry, that's all right. Let's see, next up, Andy is gonna get word of this newscaster audition. And he has some strong feelings about it.
He's gonna storm into the Annex and confront Clark, he's gonna say, what is this that I hear about you wanting to film Aaron in various outfits in your apartment. My big question is, what specific outfits does she need? Oh, Andy. He buys into it too. What an idiot.
Also, at 13 minutes and 23 seconds, this has probably been there the whole episode, but it's when I finally noticed that Andy has a grappling hook on his pants. Oh, the thing that like if you're climbing a mountain, you have to put the thing. He's got that hanging off his pants and also he started wearing these puffy vest coats. This is all from his outward bound experience. Yes. Yes.
He's ready to climb if needed. Yep. I also wanted to point out in this scene at 13 minutes and 32 seconds, Pete is eating a container of baby carrots just like Jim always does. Maybe he is Jim Jr. Well in the kitchen, a few folks have gathered around. Jim and Pam are basically playing the newlywed game. Kevin wants a lot of personal questions and angels like no. Toby knows all of Pam's answers. Pam's first celebrity crush, John Stamos. And then it moved quickly to Johnny Depp, which Toby also knew.
And then he says, sorry, I was having a separate conversation with Kevin. And then Kevin at the end says, what's the craziest place you ever made? Whoopi, he brings this question back. This is his question. Yeah. And Angela says, Kevin, stop it with that question.
That was improvised. That last couple of Kevin isn't supposed to bring it back. Angel isn't supposed to say anything. But we just kept going. They let the cameras roll. We just kept going. When I was watching the scene, it made me remember that when I was younger, before I ever moved to LA, growing up, I had two really big celebrity crushes. Okay. Like posters on my wall, buying the team beat magazines. Yeah. Huge.
Huge, I never had a celebrity poster on my wall. Really? Never. Okay, I did. And when I got to LA, early in my acting career, I got cast in movies with both of my celebrity crushes. Can you share who they are? I will not share who they are.
What? Because. You gotta listen out there and then not tell us? Because when I met them in real life, I was disappointed. I was not disappointed, but I was in no way attracted to them at all. Like, I couldn't believe it.
I was like, how is this possible? Like, nothing. Like, dead inside. Didn't find them hot. Didn't get any butterflies. Couldn't have been less interested. I found it so fascinating. It happened twice.
Wow. Twice. It wasn't that they were any less good looking or whatever, but it was just nothing. Huh. I mean, I guess my only real true celebrity crush has been Kiana Reeves. He's never been on a poster in my room,
but he is on a coffee mug I have. But you've never met him in real life. No, but remember I had that moment where my friend Wyatt said that Kiana was on a motorcycle and checked out my... Yeah, that's right. And I'm gonna hold on to that forever, whether it was really Kiana or not. Someone on a motorcycle checked out your touch. And that was 20 years ago, but I'm gonna hold on to it.
Hold on to it. Yeah. Even if it was just a stranger on a motorcycle, you're holding that dear. Somebody took a double take. Well, during this scene, Jim is gonna get another phone call and he's gonna excuse himself. Yeah.
Wow. And then he has a talking head where he says, you know what, I'm not going to tell her till it's real. And Pam has a talking head where she says maybe there is something I don't know about Jim. I think this is a good time to talk about our friend Miles McNut because he had a lot of thoughts on this storyline. Oh, we haven't heard from Miles in a bit.
I can't wait. I live for our Miles McNut reviews. Well, Miles actually stopped writing reviews for the office at the end of season eight, but the new reviewer was out this week, the week of Roy's wedding. So Miles wrote this review. This was his final review of the office. He gave this episode to be, and he reviewed this episode, but he also kind of gave some thoughts about the new direction of season 9, which he was liking very much. For example, he loves Jerk Andy. Okay, he liked that change.
He likes the addition of Clark and Pete, and he loved the Jim Pamp storyline. Here's what he said, quote, it's the couple's strongest storyline in a long time, and it's also giving the show the kind of arc structure that it lacked last season. Heck, it's even retroactively giving last season meaning, with Jim and Pam's boring storylines now becoming a period within their larger arc, which was underserved and often outright ignored in season eight,
which I actually thought was such a good point. We barely checked in on Jim and Pam's relationship in season eight, and now this idea that their relationship was too boring to check in on is becoming a major story point. So genius of Greg to think of this. He went on to say, no matter how cynical I might be about other parts of the show, I am too invested in Jim and Pam's characters to not respond
to this new characterization, one that asked big questions the show seemed too chicken to ask over the past few years. And as a reviewer who has always been more invested in the dramatic side of the show than others, Jim's decision to keep his new job a secret and the introspective and retrospective qualities of the storyline are resulting in the strongest emotional connection I've felt with the show since Steve Carell's departure. Wow.
I think that I had to read that because I'm really, really proud because John and I got to be a part of crafting this. And Greg really listened to us. And we wanted all the things that he just said to land on the audience. So I was so happy. Also, Miles is such a good writer. Can we just say that? I know. Everything he wrote there, I was like, yes! I know. I kind of opened up to how I'm looking at the season now. I felt so seen when I read it.
And then also Miles signed off in this way. He said, and Ernest, thank you to everyone who has read or commented on my review of the show over the past two years. It's been incredibly rewarding and enjoyable to go head to head about a show that people connect with so personally and have strong opinions about. And I'll admit that I'll likely be dropping in and out of the comments as the season goes on. However, I do so not as a critic but as a viewer. So do feel free to insult my person as you would any other commenter with whom you strongly disagree.
It's only fair. Miles, we're going to miss your reviews. Yes, miles. You have made this rewatch so enjoyable. I've loved your insight and your thoughts. I'm sad that we won't have any of your reviews for Dwight and Angela's. I know. Rekindling. And and I would have loved to see your reviews on the Senator and Oscar. Yes, Angela, that storyline is not in this episode and he didn't comment on it, but I have to believe that he loved it as much as we do. Or would have had some very interesting thoughts. I welcome either. Maybe I'll have to check the comments as we go along.
Oh, yes. Miles, we might look for you in the comments. Yep. See, if Miles is there and Steve B. Yeah, that's right. Steve B, aka Steve Burgess. Or so we think. Defending the show.
Well now, Darryl and Andy are gonna call a voluntary meeting in the conference room to discuss Aaron's confidence, but also like her body. Well, basically her outward appearance. Because once again, I guess in order to be a newscaster, it's all about your looks, it doesn't matter about your journalism degree.
Or not for this news job. That's right. We also are going to learn in a Darrell talking head that he has become Andy's conciliary or also known as the Assistant Regional Manager. Yeah. So I want you guys to know, Darryl is going to be part of several scenes with Andy and Aaron as they figure out how she's going to be a news anchor.
There's a bunch of deleted scenes, too. I'll share them when they come up. Well, when this conference room begins, there's an interesting moment. We got a fan question about it from Kaylee F. in Hawaii. I hope I'm pronouncing your name correctly. Who said Angela? What are you saying to Oscar in the conference room when Andy Reveals Aaron's pursuit of an anchor person audition? It seems a little out of character that you're just chatting with your friend. He's such a great catch. So in the shooting draft, Angela and Oscar had a lot of back and forth comments about Aaron being a news anchor and they seemed to have really bond over being judgy about it.
Some of it may deleted scenes, let's hear it. Does everyone have any experience? Has she taken any journalism classes, maybe? Has she done the pageant circuit? No, I watched this. She's going to be amazing. Look at her. She's going to light up the screen. Does she even want to do it? Of course she wants to do it. She's gonna be amazing. Look at her. She's gonna light up the screen. Does she even wanna do it? Of course she wants to do it.
She answers phones. It's not fair, Angela. Some people don't aspire for anything higher than that's just fine for sure. Hey, over here. So what happens is when they were trimming the scene, some of this back and forth got trimmed, but the end of it is there where Oscar and I
are kind of leaning over and he's like, Agile, that's not fair. I'm like, okay, fine. Well, if you say so. And we're having our little hub hub hub hub. Okay. And then Aaron is meant to interrupt us and say, hey, over here, I want to do this.
So you're catching us having this little hub hub. But Oscar and I were such long time friends. We had met years before the office. I've shared this We had performed in sketch comedy together We were so giddy about having any kind of storyline together and and and this season in particular we get to have a lot So a lot of that I do think you see the friendship that's there that maybe Angela and Oscar didn't have to the extent that we hadn't real life. Andy is now going to ask everyone to name something they like about
Aaron's body so that she can feel more confident about her audition. Darryl says he likes her hair. Andy says that attractive people appear more trustworthy and Oscar is going to object and kind of bring up Walter Cronkite's reign as the most trusted man in America. And then Meredith is gonna say, she thought Walter Cronkite was hot and would take that mustache ride. Go to 15 minutes and 56 seconds. What will I see?
You will see Angela Martin making a face, Jim making a face, and Creed looking inquisitive slash making a face. I took a screen grab of it, I'll put it in stories. I love it. Erin is going to do a mock reading for Daryl and Andy. She has written her news copy and it doesn't make any sense. But the thing that they are going to give her a note about is how long she pauses between saying for Channel 11 news? I'm Erin Hannon. No longer pause, even longer.
It's going to build suspense, don't be shy. There are more scenes of Andy working with Erin while Darryl, poor Darryl has to sit there and watch this. Here's one I need you to hear. But I'm really bad at public speaking. Don't think of it as public speaking. Think of it as music. The news is music.
You sing it. Momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, good, good, good, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, MMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMM Mom, mom, you're welcome. I have to say there is a melody to the way newscasters speak. Yes. And this is reminding me of something I saw on Instagram. It's this husband and he goes up to his newscaster wife and he's like, babe, how do you say I told you so in news speak? And then she thanks for a second and then she does it.
It's so fun. Will you give me a second to find it? Yeah. Hey babe. Yeah. How do you say I told you so in the anchor boys? Good evening. Your time now is on 52 on Jeanette Reyes.
This just into our newsroom. It did not take experts to project that this would be the outcome. In fact, this gentleman's wife told him on multiple occasions, will it happen again? You betcha. That's great. Isn't that funny? There's a whole bunch, but I do hear the mama mama mama mama mama mama mama. Yeah. In this deleted scene to the other part of it that you can't see on the podcast is the whole time Andy and Erin are like, momma, momma, momma, momma, Darrell is just sitting there like this pained expression. Ah, well, meanwhile, I think we should mention that after
signing this Taliban contract in the silly font, Nelly has stolen Dwight's pen, the consequences for which are cutting off her hand. If Dwight believes in Taliban rule and she stole from him, then he's gonna need to cut off her hand. So they go to the break room and they're kind of having a standoff. Is he gonna chop off her hand or is he not? Yeah. I guess Darrell as the new Consulieri assistant regional manager, he's going to come and
problem solve this moment. Yeah. Darrell brings his laptop in the break room. He says, you know what? I want you guys to watch this movie for inspiration. It's called 127 hours. And Dwight and Nelly reluctantly watch it. Do you know what this movie is about?
I couldn't remember. Yes, I do. Yeah. I could not remember what it was, and then I looked it up and I was like, oh yeah! It's based on a true story. Yes, it came out in 2010.
It's a survivalist drama. I mean, that's right up my alley, right? It was co-written and directed by Danny Boyle, and it's based on the true story of Mountain Climber Aaron Ralston, who got trapped under a boulder for 127 hours. Yes, where he was trapped was his arm. Yes, I mean, spoiler alert.
In order to get out, he had to amputate his own arm, using the dull blade from a pocket knife. I mean, and then after that, he still had to crawl out and get to safety. Yeah, but it came down to, I'm gonna die here, because no one's gonna find me. Yeah, his phone didn't work. He's like underground. Sort of like in a car-
Like in a car- Yes, exactly. And so he had to like face this, my God, survival, moral dilemma of like, if I chop off my own arm and climb out of here, I have a chance of living, but if I don't, I die here. Did you ever read that Stephen King short story? It's in his book of short stories about the guy who gets trapped on an island and he starts slowly eating himself. No. Yeah, in order to stay alive, he's like, I'll just cut off my pinky finger and then I'll beat it. And that's like how he is staying alive.
And he's like slowly amputating parts of himself for food. Oh God. Mm-hmm. Does he survive? I don't think he does. Oh God. Also, what happens is at a certain point, like, you get infections.
No, he just like, he can't use his limbs anymore to cut because he's eaten them. I believe is what happened. Oh, Lord. I mean, I'm sure he also got infections. I think the story doesn't go there. Okay. Well, where are we? Well, they end up watching the whole movie. They seem to have enjoyed it. And their storyline ends with them accusing each other of being stupid. Yeah. And no hand-chopping occurs.
No. So I guess Darrell's distraction worked because they end up getting in an argument about the movie instead. Good job, Darrell. Way to go, Darrell. Meanwhile, Pam is still trying to find out what's up with Jim. She tries to tell him the story about running into an old friend who flirted with her,
and she's sorry she didn't tell him sooner. Hint, hint. She's sorry she kept it from him, hint, hint. And he says, no, no you didn't. You would have told me. And she's like, yeah, I would have told you. I would have told you. Yeah. Unlike something you're not telling me.
Jim still doesn't effing tell her. Jim, she knows. You've got to know she knows at this point. So uncomfortable. Well, now back to this Andy and Aaron, News Anchor Audition storyline. Remember how earlier I told you Pete is going to try to tell Aaron, this is a bad idea. This isn't going to work out. But it got deleted.
It's in the deleted scenes. I want to play it for you. The way it's set up is Aaron is running some errands and she's waiting for the elevator, you know, in the lobby. Sure. And Pete walks up there alone while she waits for the elevator and he's going to say, hey, and share with her what he thinks about all this. Let's hear it.
Hey. Hey, I'm buying newspapers. Erin, this is a bad idea. I usually take the stairs. I just thought I would give myself a treat. I meant your audition. I just feel like the chances of this working out are a slim to none, you know, or are none to none. Like they start at none and then they just stay there.
That is not nice. I'm gonna take a stairs. I have a lot to say about this deleted scene. Okay. And here it is. It bothered me in this episode that Pete didn't just say the truth. Yeah. So in the shooting draft, when he approaches her at the elevator and he kind of fumbles through this, he says, this is never going to happen, right?
We just listen to it. Then he would have changed tactics. He would have been like, okay, that didn't work. But Pete in the shooting draft is determined to prevent her from going alone to Clark's apartment. And he comes up with this kind of ruse. Instead of calling out Clark as being a creeper, he just makes sure that Aaron is not alone. Well, that's all fine and good, Angela,
but I wish he would have just said the truth. Yeah, we don't need to protect the creepers, I guess is my point. Oh, absolutely. But I did want to show that he was trying throughout this to deter her. Ultimately, what happens is Andy Pete and Aaron show up to Clark's apartment. Yes.
Andy is now the co-anchor. Yes. And he's taking his job very seriously. I love it when Clark's like, I think you guys got it. And he's like, no, I didn't. I don't got it. She did great. She did great.
I need a close-up. I need you to go in tighter. Yeah. Aaron, why don't you go have dinner with Pete? All of this backfires for Clark. And it also shows how Andy doesn't see Aaron. He just sees himself always. Yeah, I did appreciate the reveals of this storyline.
Well, I'll have you know, Clark's apartment was located on Kester Avenue in Sherman Oaks. We shot these scenes after all of the stuff at Roy's house. It was a really big day for our crew. They had to do what is called a company move where they pack up everything from one location and move to a second location. It's a big deal. So this was a long day for them. It was a long day and it was triple digits outside. Yeah. And then the diner that we shot at, we did actually shoot this on a different day. This was the hungry fox on Sherman Way and Van Aes. It is right by our studio. It was Greg's
favorite place. He would go there in the mornings before work and eat breakfast and go over his notes and do his thinking. And then he would come into work. We also shot some Roy Pam scenes there. It's really good food. I have to tell you, one morning I was driving into work and I went early. I was very pregnant and I just was like, I want a big, big breakfast before I even walk onto set. So I got up really early.
I wasn't sleeping great anyway towards the end of your pregnancy. You know you don't really feel great. And I went to the hungry fox so early and I ordered myself this huge breakfast and in walked Greg. Yeah. And he was like,
what are you doing here? I was like, I was just really hungry. And so we had breakfast together. Well everyone, that was Roy's wedding. A big thank you to Tim Meadows. Yes. For joining us, everybody, please go see our Mean Girls movie. It opens this Friday.
We had so much fun making it. And, oh my gosh, I'm excited to see it on the big screen. I'm so excited. My daughter's so excited. A bunch of her friends are going to see it. Jenna, this is so fun. It's my big moment, it's a big moment. And also, of course, thank you to Steve Burgess
and to all of you for writing in with your questions and your great observations. Yes, and I would say thank you to Miles McNut. Oh, for two years of awesome reviews that were always interesting, if not hilarious. We'll be looking for you in the comments. That's right. We'll see you guys next week.
See you then! [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keeper. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco.
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.